I'm guessing that most of you have some
background in Python or you wouldn't be
here anybody consider themselves a
complete noob and you're wondering
what's going on good ok
then I can move at a fairly rapid clip
keep coming in on for those who are not
familiar with the facility the outlets
are it's sort of buried in the carpeting
on the floor there's metal plates if you
need to to route about and open them up
so I I wrote a bunch of books for Packt
publishing and one of those books is
functional Python programming and so the
there's a kind of a Genesis between
having done this presentation and then
written the book and then revising this
presentation and so I have to confess
that every time I've done this I've
there's been one more thing that I want
to add so I may add stuff to the slides
as we go which is sort of rude but oh
well sorry there's a version of this on
github
out in the world outside Capital One
that's quite a bit older than this and
so that's the other thing I have to do
this afternoon is actually take this
version and put it out there in the in
the public github repo I'll show you the
link in a little bit but it's just sort
of fair warning this is an evolving and
a rapidly evolving subject as as my
understanding deepens and and as the
language matures a little bit most of
this is pretty stable stuff but the
problem is there's always some new
clever engineering thing that Nets out
to like functional composition and like
oh wait we need to we need to think
about this in this context of functional
programming in Python so what I want to
talk about today are the five kinds of
Python functions I want to talk about
ordinary function definitions that we
all know and love and that we learned
day two of our our first introductions
to Python I want to talk about
higher-order functions because Python is
packed solid with really cool
higher-order functions like map and
reduce and turns out property and and
you know a few other things I want to
talk about function wrappers around
class methods they're not like different
different it's still a function so how
can I call this different and the answer
is they're kind of a special semantics
so like the Len function we know what it
does it goes to a collection and it uses
the dunder Len method of the collection
and I think that is a
kind of a special place in the world of
functions in Python so I think they
deserve kind of recognition and as
you're designing your own stuff there a
thing you're gonna want to think about
doing lambdas of course are confusing to
some people and not confusing to some
people they're a different kind of
function because the syntax is different
so we have to look at those callable
objects are near and dear to my heart
because it allows you to break a vast
number of rules in a vast number of very
clever ways decorators are a kind of
higher order function they kind of are
but maybe they kind of aren't we can
debate that offline perhaps at the
social event tomorrow night and I want
to talk a little bit about generator
functions in the yield statement because
those really are a different kind of
function those are fundamentally
different from the other four or so
kinds of functions that are up there and
at this point you've all said you know
Steve that was a whole lot more than
than five kinds of functions and well
yes if you want to split hairs with me
seven and five or different numbers but
the tricky part as far as I'm concerned
is that higher-order functions and
decorators are really just functions
this is Python they're not that special
if you're used to doing this in God's
save you c++ or god save you C sharp or
all the gods pulled together save you if
you've tried to do this in c ؈
higher-order functions are really
special and rare and wondrous thing but
in Python meant but just have a function
use a function as an argument who really
cares and that's the way it's supposed
to be those other languages Ludo so
while yes these other functions are
different they're really not enough
different so I'm gonna kind of lump them
together into approximately five
categories even though technically there
may be as many as
seven ways of classifying these things
and those of you who are real data
scientists no classification is hard I'm
a DevOps guy so I just learned that a
little while ago from a real data
scientist and said oh you people have
already thought about this you're so
clever when I grow up I want to be a
real scientist so at least in principle
you know how to shake out like this with
a couple of opportunities for breaks you
know so you can get water in coffee and
also so you can type the code there's a
variation on this class that takes a
half a day which is a lot of patience
really we were to put up with me for
four hours but then you get to do all
the typing and get a complete kind of
your own personal notebook full of all
the five functions we only have 90
minutes so some of the typing is gonna
fly by real quick is everybody here a
Python 3 person go ahead put your hand
up if you're a Python 2 person I will
shame you publicly if you're still using
Python 2 it will be humiliating yeah you
know the two to three tool and
eventually you got to do it have you
seen the Python countdown clock python
countdown google it it's you got till
2020 and there's a website that lists
this is the day and time at which we are
going to stop support on Python 2 so
when you get into that argument with
people who say it ain't broke so I don't
know why we are fixing it you can say as
of January 2020 it will be broke that
way you can kind of raise the threat
level on that and perhaps get get to the
Python 3 stuff so most of the material
in here is I wrote the words at least
Python 3 6
there are type hints in here so this is
properly Python 3 7 stuff who here is
using type hints on a regular basis yeah
I'm so happy to hear that all my god I'm
in the process of rewriting one of my
books to include every example working
through my PI boy did I write
and stuff like seriously like it worked
it passed unit tests works really
reliably I actually stole some of it
from production code but then you put it
through my pint it's like oh wait that
is kind of sketchy now that you mention
it and my PI is objecting to this and
objecting to that say well yeah tuple in
a listener oh no they really aren't the
same thing are they oh darn it so it's
that time so this is the I'm slot 56 out
in the world on github and so the other
55 slots I don't know who they are but
I'm number 56 and so the five kinds of
Python functions is out there you will
notice that it's a completely different
color scheme with completely different
fonts because it's the slightly older
version of this but it's similar in many
respects for folks that are weak on math
a function is a mapping between a domain
and a range and so I provide this as AZ
level setting to make sure that
everybody in the room is down with this
and so here's an example bit of code
here the ABS function in Python you know
you apply it to a an argument in the
domain of numbers and you get back a
response in the range of numbers so when
we look at other functions div might be
in one of my faves the domain can be
thought of as an ordered pair a and B or
you can think of it as two arguments I
think it's very helpful to look at these
things as if the argument is an ordered
pair which is like magically decomposed
into the the two values by the function
definition and the reason I think that's
helpful is because of course the return
value when you return you're technically
returning a tuple that is decomposed by
the assignment statement and so this is
kind of a mapping tuple of intz to tuple
of intz
you don't formally declare it that way
but I think it's very helpful to think
of it that way so that the domain is a
pair the range is a pair philosophically
makes it a little more symmetric I think
it makes a little easier to reason about
there's some seats down front this is
what the pastor always says in my church
their seats down front come on down so
what's important about mathematical
functions the reason for level setting
this is mathematical functions
technically have no hysteresis no memory
of whatever came before they also use
the word idempotence to talk about this
that the the response is always the same
so I have my piece of Python code down
here int of 1o f 1 and 16 is going to
give you that number 4 3 3 7 always it
is idempotent
every time you evaluate that function
you get the same answer back again
crucial for reasoning about functions
the backbone of mathematical philosophy
since I don't know 5 8,000 years ago
however long ago they invented the very
idea of functions this is the way it's
supposed to be however in the computer
world we tend to break the rules and so
here are some things that are perfectly
ordinary looking functions that have
memory of what happened in the past the
random number generator if it didn't
have hysteresis what would it do it
would generate the same damn random
number every time wait let me get my
dice out here 3 it's a random number
guaranteed random I rolled it on the
dice every time it returns 3 a random
number and that would not be your
expectation of how the random function
would work but it would be idempotent
and that would be kind of handy
sometimes
the other one is stuff that depends on
the operating system so the entire OS
module is chock-full of functions whose
values are not idempotent because you
can change things in the operating
system and those functions have new
values and that's a little weird and
sometimes hard to reason about it's what
we expect it's not like surprising in
fact it's sort of surprising when
tried to insist functions should be
idempotent because you look at these and
say well they aren't okay so there's a
special case of some functions that
break the rules so that's the sort of
foundational stuff on functions domains
ranges and this idea of no hysteresis no
memory of what happened before so and we
can move on to ordinary Python functions
with the caveat that this may be a lot
of needless detail because almost
everybody already gets this so I but I
like to go through it carefully so that
I can enumerate a few details so you've
seen this kind of thing to find some
function with parameters there's a body
and then there's often but not always a
return statement and so when we talk
about domain and range the DEF provides
the name it provides parameter names
from which we kind of infer a domain
it's not really fully formally declared
the body I I note down here is optional
the return statement is also optional so
you can get away with just putting the
word pass in there to have a completely
stubbed out function that doesn't do
anything we'll come back to the return
rules in a second I want to show you an
odd little function that we're gonna
look at for a while here and if n true
if n is odd it has a doc string does
everybody use docstrings all the time
who doesn't put doc strings in all the
time put your hand up i will shame you
for not putting doctor things all the
time what are you thinking I use the
help on the command line and your
functions aren't giving me any help oh I
am hmm
so consider putting doc strings in here
and there because they can help people
like me so I don't have to shame you
publicly for not putting in docstrings
all the time so the domain here and all
we have is a parameter name
traditionally in Python we know that n
probably ought to be number or like
because we're using the percent operator
but we do know that strings also work
with the percent operator so there's no
real serious guarantee that this is
going to work or that this is going to
break for a string it might actually
work it doesn't but it might for the
right kind of string it will work so the
range of values we can sort of infer
from this because it's a boolean
expression that the range of this is
boolean and it doesn't have any doc test
cases in the doc string but I you know I
was happy I had a doc string in there so
let's not go too far down that road now
the return statement technically the
statements optional if you omit the
entire statement it's like you wrote
returned none you can write returned
which returns none but the most
important thing is returning an
expression that expression is the result
of the function the actual range of the
function is the expression on the return
statement so when you think back to the
Foundation's mapping domain to range the
parameters are the domain that
expression of the return statement is
the range that is the single most
important thing in the function is that
expression on the return statement
everything else is just enough stuff to
get you to the place where I can return
a simple expression so the fundamental
rule here is that the whole point of a
function is just to encapsulate that
expression on the return statement and
really all we're doing is reasoning
about that expression which means we can
just do ordinary algebra on it which is
a very helpful thing to be able to do
the statements are sort of optional and
some common use cases for statements are
things like an if statement to choose
among some alternatives or possibly a
for loop to do a for all kind of
quantification on some data but other
than that the statements are nominally
optional and in a real strict formal
sense the statements are only there to
choose an expression
so we've noted that Python declarations
are pretty spare there's actually no
real parameter types and there's no real
return types it's just a names of the
parameters and occasionally it comes up
from folks that aren't intimate with
Python how is this possible for this to
work at all and it it shows up in places
like you'll get like Stack Overflow
questions where somebody says how can
you call Python a properly
object-oriented language if it doesn't
have variable declarations
well the objects have the types bound
into them permanently I don't need to
type in a variable declaration the
object has its type in it permanently
and you can't get out of that so that
whenever I make a reference to an object
with an operator if the objects type
response to that operator it works if
the objects type doesn't respond to that
operator it fails at runtime and that
relationship between the object and its
type cannot be broken
there's no cast like there isn't C++
where I can claim these bytes have a
different meaning nothing like that this
is the type of binding is really really
permanent and so in the case of my odd
function I'm using the percent operator
the percent operator is implemented by
dunder mod or dunder R mod and so any
object that implements those methods
will work with the percent operator and
will work with the odd function so I
could create dates or some other kind of
crazy thing not technically a number if
I implement the right methods it'll
respond to the operator I can use it in
my odd function everything flows
normally it's really an elegant elegant
system where the high-level operators
are implemented by these dunder methods
we'll come back and look at this a
little bit more but it is the secret for
building superclass things that do super
cool stuff using the built-in operators
everybody here use path Flibe I don't
see enough hands going up let me ask one
more time does everybody here use path
lab because path lab uses the slash
operator to build operating system pets
and people the first time they see code
with path lab they say you can't do
division between a path and a string not
doing division in the path live objects
the slash operator concatenates path
segments together it looks just like a
file system path with the slash operator
it's the most wonderful thing ever and
it just works through dunder diff and
dunder RDF - to assemble up complex
paths out of individual strings I'm
going to show some examples as we go
forward with type hints for those of you
who may not be completely familiar with
them this is what they look like with a
like this n colon int and is the
parameter name that's an official part
of Python can't get away from that the
colon int is a hint that n should
probably ought to be an integer type
hints have no runtime cost and I'll
repeat that for those of you are still
really a packed full of lunch type hints
have no runtime cost they're free put
them in your code a tool like my PI will
look at the type hints and tell you your
code is garbage in your garbage and you
should feel bad about your garbage code
an argument my PI and I have been having
since I started working on a book where
I have to type into all my old examples
but it's only at my PI time as part of
continuous integration continuous
deployment where you might look at the
type intz turn my PI loose to reason
about your code decide whether or not
function parameters and function
arguments align with each other and
whether or not this is going to work at
run time no cost so include them and
I've annotated my odd function here the
end argument is an integer the expected
result is going to be a bully
and then I've got this you know an
ampersand
to not equal to zero kind of thing that
does it it is a huge improvement in
clarity future you will thank past you
for having included it because future
you is gonna look at this code in three
months and go what did I mean by that Oh
returns a boolean right right right
that's what that means and it says it
right there in front of God and
everybody so that there's no question
about it and when you finally get the
mypie stuff to run very cleanly you also
get a clean bill of health from my PI
that the arguments the parameters and
the function return types all aligned
there's a processing graph that can be
built around your application that says
that the data objects all match up and
that there's really unlikely to be a
bigger problem and I mentioned also if
you're putting in docstrings you
probably ought to put in doc test
examples and so you can run this with
the Python minus M doc test and all of
the examples everything with the greater
greater greater this code should give
that answer they all get checked
independently of anything else you
happen to be working on so any kind of C
ICD pipeline probably ought to run doc
tests on every file you own every time
and yeah
yes you can include the default
parameter thing is going to be a
slightly expanded syntax and colon int
equals two and then you can have the
default value and the type all in one it
does get long and so when you start
thinking about your default parameters
and your type declarations it becomes a
little wordy and gets vaguely java-like
and so you begin to start to regret your
lifestyle choices at that moment but
what you wind up doing is you wind up if
you if you work with it a little bit you
wind up creating um type variables or
they don't really type variables type
names that summarize a fairly big thing
with a terse little name because as you
work through that the the the type
hinting the built-in data structures you
have list Dyck set all those things
tuple you can define that this is a dict
that map's string to list that map's
integers and stuff and you can have this
big long type declaration to describe a
kind of a complicated built in Python
type you maybe ought to give those names
you don't have to but if you do then you
sort of forced to reason about it a
little more carefully saying oh this
thing that is a dick that map's a string
to a list is really a bag it is a
multiset and i'm using the dictionary to
implement of all they said so maybe I
should just call this bag of customer
transactions and I have a nice terse
name that clearly specifies what it is
and it's a type int but I didn't
officially declare a class for it I just
gave it a type name and then my
functions got short and we're still
readable so that's that sermon meanwhile
are there other questions
you hit my timing perfectly because that
was the net yeah
this stuff is news me so let's say we
had a more aliasing yeah you just say
form a panda's data frame of arbitrary
values for the test cases there is it
deeply was enough like a same way you
could import a library in a unit test
framework and then construct something
classic to it you are yes you can use
doc tests with pandas that will work the
problem is that your pandas examples
tend to be kind of bigger because almost
anything you do in bandhas tends to be
kind of elaborate and complicated or you
would be using pandas so doc tests for
pandas examples sometimes it's a good
idea sometimes it's not if it gets
cumbersome then it suddenly become a bad
idea and you should just go to
straight-up PI test and not be messing
with this so and and the question is
when's it become cumbersome and the
answer is all of these things you'll
notice it's the the greater greater
greater prompt like I had to type that
in so if your pandas example gets so big
you can't physically type it in anymore
that's the hint that this really should
be done in PI tests and it you know
we're failing the doc test thing because
I can't even type the example it's too
sophisticated
mabye anymore you know this is a good
hand ringy question and I'm really glad
a thoughtful person like you asked a
question like that from a person like me
next next question yeah you've sort of
got to do it I mean they have to be in
there because Sphinx may be Sphinx too
can find the type hints if they're there
I can't remember so you got to figure
that maybe Sphinx 2.1 or 2.2 is gonna go
find the type hints for you and you
won't really need them and then you can
just do Purim name and nothing more and
it'll all kind of work out better
so the tooling is migrating really
really rapidly so I wouldn't get too
worried about having a formal position
on that because I suspect strongly in
six months the tooling will be a lot
cooler already the things that use numpy
style comments there's a lot of parsing
that has to go on to turn a numpy
comment into HTML and I kind of think
those tool streams are going to be
pretty clever also and this is all the
type hint information is available
through introspection don't go too far
down that road into metaprogramming
lands but but it is available so a lot
of stuff can be done pretty cleverly
from from from a sophisticated tool
chain
anything else on basic machinery of
functions and stuff cool
higher-order functions I love this stuff
a lot because as far as I can tell the
core of computer science is functional
composition and so and and this kind of
lays it open in you know in a very cool
way and the barrier to entry because of
the Python language is really really low
and that you just do it and it works
perfectly there's not a lot of extra
syntax machinery involved in this so the
the point here is that when you're
talking about higher-order functions
it's the functions are going to have
arguments that are functions or results
that are functions and so it's functions
dealing with functions and it works in
python trivially because functions
already are objects because in Python
everything's an object when you think
about other languages like C let's not
think about other languages like C if
you were forced to think about another
language like C if somebody took away
your scotch and forced you to think
about another language like C then you
have to look at the runtime
implementation of a function which is a
stream of stupid instructions in
bare-metal world where did the function
disappear - it's gone it loses his
identity in compiled C code yes there's
a function name which is an address
somewhere in memory but the function as
a thing kind of loses its identity its
just stream of instructions in Python
the function still first-class object
it's got names it's got properties you
can modify the properties don't but you
can it's got a code object hanging off
of it you can modify the code object the
code object has the byte code inside it
you can modify that but don't because I
will come and get you but you could
so other languages this higher-order
function thing is necessarily
complicated because it gets compiled
down to bare metal and the function
loses its identity we don't have that
problem so here is the most trivial
example I could find for treating a
function as an object I assigned my odd
function to another variable and now I
have two references to the same
underlying function one is not even the
other is odd and so not even if three
works perfectly it just does exactly
what it's supposed to do because they're
two references to the same underlying
object this is a wonderful thing and
this because it works so perfectly and
logically this is what opens the door to
higher-order functions so let's look at
some other slightly more complicated
version here I've got a function I've
called my shabby log because this is a
terrible way to do debugging logging but
it does work and works really really
well and you can slap this into code
without having to do too much work so
I've got a function that is I've
provided a type int of callable pretty
vague the value is got a type hint of
any which couldn't be too much more
vague and the return type is any so this
is a function that takes another
function and an argument and returns a
result of some kind and so I'm gonna
print out the function it was given and
the value it was given and then I can
actually apply the function to the value
so I've received a function as an
argument and I've applied that function
and so I can you know this shabby long
thing and it prints out what function it
was called with and stuff like that
so there's the glory of this not useful
practically but the glory of it is
there's hardly anything to it there's no
asterisks is eeoc's there's no
ampersands there's no complicated syntax
overhead just take a function as an
argument use the thing like it's a
function and if it's callable it will
work if the thing you pass in as the
first argument too shabby log is not
callable doesn't adhere to the callable
protocol then you die at runtime and
that you deserve what you get
because but this is a relatively
straightforward thing using higher-order
functions so that this is just in case
you haven't thought about it too much
before this is the model that all the
higher-order functions have in common so
I'm gonna look at a more useful one the
map function you know when you talk
about Map Reduce this is the map I'm
going to apply a function to a bunch of
arguments in in of course big Map Reduce
I'm applying a big process to a lot of
datasets in small Map Reduce I'm
applying a function to some argument
values and and it accumulated a list of
the results there so that you would
actually see something it is exactly as
if the function was individually mapped
to each argument and then the whole
thing all executed question yeah
well you could also use comprehension
yeah yes and in fact the map and the map
higher order function analysts
comprehension are the same thing we're
almost identical in what they will do
the map actually can take multiple
arguments and it will do an implicit zip
and there's some other variations like
star map and whatnot in itertools the
difference in syntax though is profound
because with the function syntax all as
list of map of thing I have a nice
fairly easy to read thing with a list
comprehension I've got this other change
in style to have the square brackets
instead of a function name not bad and
if it's used well it's a nice thing this
allows me to find the mappings like that
and find the mappings that got turned
into lists like that and the other thing
that this explicitly does that a list
comprehension doesn't do and we'll come
back to this in a little bit is
generator expressions versus list
comprehensions map is technically a
generator it's lazy when I apply list
I've explicitly built something out of
it and so the difference between a list
comprehension and a generator expression
can sometimes be very subtle and lost on
people why is this so slow oh my god it
takes forever yeah cuz it's building a
damn list and it's filling memory with
objects if you had used the generator
expression then it would have been lazy
and it would not have filled memory with
objects so I kind of like this syntax
because I think it's a little clearer
but your mileage will certainly vary
with you know your reading audience and
your future self other
so this is my case study I lived at a
boat for a long time and so I became
intimate with the diesel engine mr.
Lehmann salute when you say that
so mr. Lehmann got a new tack ometer for
his birthday one year and so this is mr.
Lehman's NewTek ometer buried down
inside the engine compartment with hoses
and wires and all the other stuff that
goes along with it so what happens this
is the other side of mr. Lehmann the the
generators on the alternators on the
opposite side this is the technically
the starboard side of the motor so
anyway what happens is that there's a
what they call serpentine belts in the
front serpentine belts are turning the
water pump and they turn the alternator
so the alternator is spinning all it is
is coils of wire and magnets so a coil
of wire moving through a magnetic field
any physicists what is wire moving
through a magnetic field oh that's the
definition of electricity and so the
alternator spinning along makes
electricity couldn't be any cooler it's
called an alternator because of course
as the coil goes past the magnets North
Pole South Pole the electricity goes out
and comes back it it it alternates boats
run on direct current so you have to use
diodes to damp that nonsense out so what
you have is a little pulse every time
one of those magnets and coils passes
each other the pulse of electricity
going back and forth which reports
indirectly
the RPMs of the engine so the tachometer
that I look at up above the engine is
based on the pulses generated from the
alternator spinning with the engine the
problem is that when I bought mr.
Lehmann his new alternator I bought new
wheels and the wheels are not the same
size so the alternator is technically
spinning faster than it used to spin
generates more current while it does
that charges the batteries faster but
but but the technolon
I took the calipers out and I measured
the wheel it's wrong by I don't know you
know 40 percent or something like
factor I'm not sure when am I gonna run
out of gas the crew wants to know are we
gonna get all the way to Beaufort North
Carolina or are we going to die here in
the Atlantic Ocean oh maybe I ought to
know exactly the different size of the
wheel so I know the exact fuel
consumption so we don't have to have
that argument at four o'clock in the
morning so what I did was I put together
a little function to map the tachometer
reading rpms to what I think the real
RPMs are so you know divided by one
point for it based on my caliper a
measurement of the size of the wheels
and so theoretically this Eng of 2100
tells me that even though the taxes 2120
100 the engines actually only turning
1500 okay so that should solve the
problem fire up the laptop use this
function and you will know the actual
RPMs and you can do your own fuel
consumption calculation and you know
that's awkward who wants to use the
laptop at 4 o'clock in the morning so
what we really want is a little table to
map the what's read on the tachometer to
so this is just a little teeny kind of a
model of the engine with a single
multiply which you know as a guy who's
not a data scientist I was really proud
of the fact that I could get my model
down to a single multiply I thought that
was that was a pretty good deal because
they don't have very many degrees of
freedom on this engine tachometer so
there is really much to look at aren't
any features to speak of just the one
but I can make a little table you know
you take the tach reading and the
derived engine value and book that's all
the code however I note it is a lot of
code for this problem
I think it's suspiciously too much code
and it's difficult to extend if I had a
better model because it's kind of wired
together in a way that I don't really
like so the what I did was
I did some real science but those are
the data samples I actually went down
and looked at the engine for a while
with a visual rpm thing and I plotted
the actual graph all right this is
pretty shabby data science isn't it so
anyway I had a few data points I plotted
a graph and I fit a curve and that's got
to multiply in an exponent but it's a
much more accurate model I wanted to
overfit it with a polynomial with like
nine terms but other data scientists
said no dude it's barely linear stop no
no but I could fit it exactly so now
I've got a function that given a
tachometer reading will give me a much
more accurate engine reading and and
predict my fuel consumption a little
more nicely and so the there's a few
sort of parts of this that are still a
little off-putting in that engine RPMs
of 1790 7.12 blah blah blah who the heck
I mean you the needle of Wiggles you
know reading it anything past the
nearest hundred is crazy
so we need to have a kind of a rounding
off thing so that we can do it to the
nearest hundred and we're really only a
range of values cuz you don't go to zero
and the engines got a governor on it it
can't actually go past 2500 really which
is gonna be both look like 3300 so
there's only these dozen values that I
need to map to so what we're really
talking about is this I want to map this
engine function against a range of
values and come up with this list
comprehension kind of thing that is
tachometer engine tech ometer engine
kind of stuff this is just the actual
engine values given tack values but it
is a really elegant little mapping so
that I can plug in different engine
models into the mapping using the map
higher-order function to apply the model
to the range of values to predict the
things what what the what the actual
engine RPMs are so I can then predict
fuel consumption after that
this I like because there's not so much
code involved in this there's no actual
loop and there's no for statement and
you know none of that nonsense it's just
a simple mapping function to range of
values I need to round where does
rounding go now we're in the functional
composition I've got this next hundred
function that'll round stuff off to the
nearest factor of a hundred and so now I
have this mapping to compute the engine
from the tachometer and a second mapping
to apply the next 100 to the results of
the first mapping now we're getting
somewhere this is a cool thing and it's
using higher-order function map to do
functional composition between couple to
three functions the next 100 the engine
two and the range so I take them three
functions and combine them together I'm
liking this a lot because we're down to
one line of code so this is a useful
kind of thing and for those of you who
are uncomfortable reading this sort of
map map map kind of thing you read it
from the inside out the innermost
expression is mapping a function to some
data and then moving to the left the
next expression is mapping another
function to the first functions result
and then the list is consuming the whole
thing I like this it can get long but on
the other hand I can combine functions
really really freely and the underlying
functions like next 100 and Eng to the
test cases for those are trivial so the
composition is very easy to test because
the underlying components the functions
that are being composed are easy to test
which makes the composition relatively
safe to test because I know the pieces
are simple and the assembly was simple
therefore the composite behavior is easy
to test it doesn't become simple anymore
sophisticated behavior can emerge from
this but
it's relatively easy to test so what I
want to do while I go find water is
leave you for for a moment to think
about taking my engine to my next 100
and somehow or other getting 2-tuples
out of this maybe using the zip function
to assemble up a bigger result and we
run dangerously close to code golf when
we think about this and nobody wins at
code golf
but on the other hand it's a relatively
straightforward function composition
that is expresses really precisely what
we're doing without a lot of statements
keep this one
yeah I gotta keep this I just figured
out I got to keep this one with me
because he's
all right I'm gonna hustle folks along a
little bit to make sure I don't run too
far over anywho I've created a range
object you Noatak equals I've created my
engine map from the range object and
I've zipped the two together to create a
nice sort of table of this thing what's
really important about doing this sort
of MapReduce processing is that the
built-in higher-order functions like map
are lazy they do not do any work until a
value needs to be consumed if a value is
not actively being consumed by some
other function like list or tuple or an
iterator in a for statement then the
generator does not do anything it is a
lot like my brother-in-law sitting
around in the couch would you get me a
beer maybe I will maybe I won't would
you get me a beer right now
ok fine he'll get up off the couch but
until there is a demand for a piece of
data a lazy generator like map or filter
does nothing so you can define a fairly
long sequence of operations but until
that Final Four statement or that final
list or that final tuple nothing happens
it's all an idea waiting to be realized
yeah nope if they are to all lazy like
map is in this case strictly lazy no
intermediate data structures created at
all so it becomes this sort of
transitive ask list once a value yo map
what do you got map says I got nothing I
got another map though there might have
some data hey other map what do you got
I got nothing range what do you got I
got a hundred oh well in that case
multiply here's your thing in that case
round off here's your thing and it goes
and it percolates out through there so
that when you have strictly lazy
functions like map then no data shows up
until there's a demand for
and it's actually marching technically
through a pipeline of processing as each
step in the map gets a chance to touch
the data so it's really elegant in many
respects because doesn't fill up memory
and so you can write some really
sophisticated map oriented pipelines
like this that that run like lightning
generator expressions fit the bill when
we get to the end and talk about writing
your own generator functions they fit
the bill
the one place you'll be surprised by
this kind of functional composition is
in the inner tools library there are a
few things in inner tools that secretly
materialize an object under the hood to
make it look nice like you're working in
Haskell when you're not and so you'll
discover that the hard way occasionally
when something sort of locks up and is
very slow and you say what's wrong with
this and you look at the implementation
and say they create a list secretly
under the hood darn them so then you
work around it or you you live with it
or whatever but map completely lazy
chains of Maps completely lazy one piece
of data flows through the whole pipeline
really really a nice way to do business
theoretically it's break time but we did
the break while we were typing so I'm
going to talk about briefly about
function wrappers this is a piece of
syntax that you see all the time in
Python like the Len function it behaves
as though it's definition is exactly the
Len dunder lend out of a underlying
objects class definition a bunch of
things work this way great bunches of
things work this way a lot of Python
works this way what happens is that the
function like this Len function
explicitly does nothing it is just
syntax to give you a function like
syntax instead of an object method like
syntax it is just sugary toppings on top
of your muffins which my partner reminds
me I don't need sugary toppings on my
muffins you should think of it as
garnish on your salad okay fine you
you can call it garnish on your salad
for me it is sugar sprinkles on my
muffin and it makes the language more
expressive because it allows you to
write using proper functions so that
everything looks really similar and that
can make the your code much easier to
understand and the specific I mentioned
a couple of modules that are full of
this sort of thing but specifically
you're given this choice here object dot
method or if you write a little wrapper
function you can say method of an object
if most of your stuff is mostly
functional that little wrapper can be
handy it can be very very helpful if
you're used to R then you're gonna want
to write a lot of those because that's
the way our looks function if they're
function after function and so why not
do it in Python the cost is really
really relatively low and the if you
stick to the basic semantic rule like
Len does land of an object is object
under Len no extra processing if you
stick to that semantic rule then these
are really pleasant real easy to use
they give you a kind of polymorphism
through functions and and it's really
really nice here's another wrapper
function example using path live I wrote
a function here home directory and it's
basically just returning path home know
of their processing it's just a pleasant
little sugary syntax topping on top of
an underlying feature and that way I can
do things in a strictly functional style
and be really really happy with it
when you're defining your own classes it
can help to also provide the functional
interface especially if your classes are
going to be used in a context where
almost everything else is functional
then then you're gonna want to do this
it also happens sometimes because there
are folks that will say Python is not
really purely object oriented because I
see function definitions and we all know
that function definitions are not object
oriented I don't know who knew that that
I was never informed of that but the
point is that it is strictly
object-oriented the function definition
is just a little sugary garnish on top
of your muffin it's doesn't
fundamentally change the way the
language works it just allows you to
have an alternative syntax which I
encourage under some circumstances
because I think it can be helpful that
it's just a sugary topping questions on
the idea of a function wrapper around a
method yeah it's a question of
encapsulation so if what the function is
doing is obviously part of the rest of
the class and depends on other things
that are inside the class yeah you
certainly want to have the method and
then maybe a wrapper so that other users
can can make good use of this thing
sometimes however your binding in stuff
that comes in from outside so I've got a
class that is you know a credit report
or somebody and I've got a thing from my
model that is some factor that I'm
bringing in to the credit report record
to create some derived data maybe that
doesn't really belong in the class
anymore and now we're doing some other
kind of functional compositions so the
the border there is the encapsulation
line is it part of the class or is it
being brought in from somewhere else
other questions I want to talk a little
bit about generator expressions like
list comprehensions but not cooler so I
mentioned my my gathering data on my
engine when I tried to do real science
so what I wound up with as my data was
this specific Python data structure and
in fact I think that's literally the
data structure I was working with copied
and pasted into keynote and I provided
the type in up top that it's technically
using the typing module from typing
import capital L list capital T tuple
those are the type hint versions of the
built-in types and so if you haven't
seen this sort of type hint structure
before I'm explicitly saying that it
it's a 2-tuple and the two elements and
the tuple are both going to be floats
and I'm gonna have a list of those
tuples and my PI can use that data
structure to reason about my code and
say are you really is it really gonna be
a list is it really gonna be a list of
tuples is it really gonna be a list of
two tuples and are they both guaranteed
to be floats and every place where
that's not true my PI is gonna get after
me and it'll be bad because I know I'm
right even though it's demonstrably not
true in the code but I knew I was right
so here I've written a little function
that that sums up a list of pairs I
vomited the type hint there but you know
some of item 0 and some of item 1 and
you see that I have what looks sort of
like list comprehension stuff item of 0
for item in list of pairs but it's in
parentheses there's no actual square
bracket there it is not creating an
intermediate list object it is creating
a generator expression some consumes
that generator expression and the
generator expression is lazy like my
brother-in-law it does nothing until
some says I need me a number
and the generator expression says what
do I got list of pairs what do you got
one number okay and I'm going to pick
item zero out of that there's your
number and some says I need a number
alright go to the list of pairs get
another number take item zero hand it
over
slowly some works its way through until
finally the generator expression that in
the parenthesis the four has run out of
values and list of pairs and raises an
exception stop iteration it's a lovely
lovely thing because that item 0 and
item 1 in those well they're obviously
trivial they could be hugely
sophisticated costly operations that are
performed only as needed just one at a
time
so however much data had to come from
the source one item at a time is
processed through that pipeline I love
it and so here's a little hint about how
to analyze these things when you've got
some function applied to a generator
expression you're gonna start inside the
generator expression with the for loop
and you're gonna use that expression
like item zero applied to each item that
comes out of the for loop and that
resulting iterable sequence of values is
what the sum function is gonna say it
doesn't know what's inside it only knows
that it's getting values from that
generator and as long as it gets values
it's happy to sum them up and eventually
an exception is raised and it silently
eats that exception oh stop iteration
kind of what I expected to see anyway
and then there's no more data it's a
lovely lovely thing if we wanted to do
it with full up Gaia yes
so in the in the some generators there
this doesn't really have anything to do
generics but I'm just curious as your
thoughts you could unpack rather than
index yes the reason why yes because I
couldn't have instead of saying item 0
for item in I could have said 4 X comma
Y X 4 X comma Y in list of pairs and
made the for statement do the unpacking
so it would be using a multiple
assignment kind of trick to split the
pairs up and there's not a great defense
for this version of things because the
list of pairs is in front of God and
everybody up above it is really a
2-tuple there's not a lot of ambiguity
in this and so why use numbered indexing
as if someday it might wander away and
become a three tuple whose name is still
pairs yeah so unpacking in the fork for
X comma Y in list of pairs is a way to
clarify really precisely what that data
structure looks like thank you
I saw another yeah
yeah just for the for people who haven't
looked at this very often I haven't seen
it before so this is with the the full
up type hint in there and as I mentioned
earlier those type Institue get long and
you should really consider saying list
of tuple the float of float
probably ought to be called like sample
pair or some other kind of type name
that more clearly specifies what its
intent is as opposed to what its
structure is names ought to specify the
intent or the meaning and then the body
the type definition gives you the
structure so in you know using those
wrapper functions I can you know some
the X values and some the Y values
pretty trivially and so clearly I can
also you know count the values and I can
I mentioned the two sums I can sum the
squares of the X's and sum the squares
of the Y's I can sum the products I will
meet it writing that one down you can
you can code that for yourself because
it should be pretty straightforward how
that's going to look and for those of
you who don't know where it's headed
this is where we're going I've got this
thing that's got sums of X's and Y's no
wait I just wrote a function whose name
was sum of X and sum of Y so I can map
that sum X sum Y notation straight into
my functions and be pretty sure I've
implemented that correctly because I'm
just basically mapping the big Sigma to
the word sum and I don't have to think
deeply about it I like that a lot
the other thing that this does for me
the count 1 is always bothersome when
you start to work with this kind of
thing you say wait wait wait why can't I
just use Landon well ya Len is the
number of items and and technically
counting 1 for I in the list of pairs is
the Len but but but what if I have to
filter oh then we're going to inject
filter functions everywhere oh wait
these things list of pairs could have a
filter applied and then I would not have
all of them in there interesting so I
can do functional composition using
filters and these sorts of things and
then take the meaningful subset of my
data without really rewriting the
algorithm and adding if statements all
over the place I can use functional
composition to bind my low-level math
functions with filters or other maps to
do transformations so I'm not going to
pause for an exercise I'm just going to
sort of fly into code but in this case I
decided to call my list of tuples in X Y
list so that I could assign the type of
name and then it's all the way through
it's clear that it's an X Y list and
those are my various functions that are
doing my various pieces of the
computation and so the correlation as a
whole like I say it's just a almost text
substitution with the big Sigma becomes
the word sum and everything else works
out really really nicely for me and I
could actually get built correlation it
turns out this is part of doing the
linear regression and then you can do
the linear regression and fit your curve
and stuff in case you don't have a
spreadsheet that does that or don't have
R on your boat because somebody forgot
to install R before he left port so I
had to do this the hard way
questions on the idea of having these
generator expressions built into
function argument lists and using them
like that it's higher art of programming
higher order functional kind of
programming it I want to talk about the
forbidden dance the Lambada
oh no wait I'm supposed to talk about
lambda so the point what lambda Z is
that it's an anonymous function a
function who has no name and has been
stripped really down to the bare
essentials I mentioned this earlier that
a function definition has got a name
it's got parameters and that expression
in the return statement was the only
real thing that really mattered that's
all the lambda is it's the parameters
and that function from the return
statement everything else has been
stripped away so you can use these in
places where a full-up function def is
overkill and the most common event where
a situation where that happens here is
this sort of thing where rather than
have an actual formal def for my engine
to function I can just lambda are
there's the body of the mapping right
there works out nicely in the edge case
where you're going to use it once if
you're gonna use it a second time you're
probably gonna want to assign it to a
variable and then you're gonna get into
arguments with people Stack Overflow
people are gonna say y'all never Auto
assign a lambda to a variable I don't
know where that's written but they'll
say that to you and so then you'll wind
up in the situation where I'm only using
it twice why do I have to have a full up
def for this can't I just assign a
lambda to a variable and I think you
sort of should be able to assign lambdas
to variables I don't think it's
inherently wrong but you lost the doc
string which means you lost the doc test
cases which means you're starting
give up a lot of things if you're gonna
use a lambda in a bunch of places so
once got it we use them a lot you know
sorted min and Max because you're some
of these cases you only occur once in
the entire application I want the min
based on some transformation mapping and
I'm gonna write the lambda once and only
once and we're good everybody's happy
with that I didn't want to assign it to
a variable and I couldn't see a point in
putting a def in for the full thing
because I only need it at the once a lot
of times you wind up with with sort of
stuff like this here's my raw data
sorted key is a lambda of the item I
want to sort by items bracket one
basically I want to sort by the Y values
you almost want to have a lambda whose
name is y value equals lambda item item
bracket one so that you can sort by Y
value then you're assigning the lambda
to a variable and then you're like wait
shouldn't I define this as a function
now it's only the Y value for the love
of God it's item bracket one how much of
a unit test case in doc test does that
need why can't I just assign that little
teeny lambda to a variable for clarity's
purposes so that I can say Y value and
have it mean lambda X X bracket one
bless you so what as you start thinking
through the higher-order functions you
discover the little anomaly here that
map and filter the function is first and
min Max and sorted the function is an
option after key and some doesn't play
well with others it doesn't accept a
function it is a lot like a reduction
but it's not because it's wired up to do
one and only one thing so I'm a little
bothered that sum doesn't have a key
equals so I can do a transformation
while I'm summing I don't really have a
good use case for it I just the
asymmetry bugged me
so here's my assigning lambdas to
variables you know it does work it works
really well it's a lot like the DEF but
you know you've lost the docstring
you're losing the unit test case doc
test cases and the type declaration is
awkward and weird looking because you
can see down there at the bottom
for those of you who are in the front
row and you can see the bottom of the
slides Engine 4 is of type hint callable
of float yields float and it's equal to
this lambda object and that is you know
kind of a long one line of code you
begin to wonder with the DEF be better
and the answer is probably yeah and when
you get in to type in ting and assigning
lambdas to variables that the the
ugliness of the hint is a meta hint that
you should maybe not be doing this
so if you wanted to think through this
super carefully you could redefine all
of these goofy little counts some X some
wise as lambdas and then you can define
higher-order statistical functions
around those and I I sort of think it's
a cool exercise not of a real lot of
actual value value but as you're working
through internalizing how these things
could be used in other applications it's
not a bad thing to do because then you
get a known answer and you say hey I
replaced all my debts with lambdas and
it worked
bonus it worked it passed unit test
cases and everything yeah as opposed to
yeah I think I see how this might work
yeah I think I see how it might work and
until it doesn't work and then obviously
I didn't understand it so rally Ottawa
Britain unit test cases any questions
right now yeah
that that I do it like all the time but
it makes me uncomfortable using a lambda
as a wrapper around the function has
many arguments yeah oh yeah um you're
the alternative is func tools partial
and so it's a first class part of the
language it's it's a thing and you you
either do it with lambda so you do it
with func tools partial and and I like
it and I have a you know done it both
ways and and I find often the lambdas
are a little more fun than func tools
partial only because partial has this
kind of syntax it's not a glitch it's
just that you know it's a function it's
going to have a function as an argument
and then the arguments as arguments and
then the positional parameters is you
know and it looks funny and so the
lambda doesn't ever look quite as funny
as partial does so I'm with you a
hundred percent on building up the
partial evaluation through a series of
lambdas so that I don't have that giant
expression with forty hundred it's forty
hundred and number
sure yeah arguments 4096 power two it's
got to be a power to write so you could
define a whole passel lambdas like this
to do statistical calculations as long
as you're willing to admit the type
hints and hope my PI can reason it out
correctly surprisingly my applied does a
pretty good job with these but I I'm not
sure I would trust it every time and so
then you probably ought to have def so
you're probably out of DOC test
strangely probably have unit test cases
and in the whole nine yards
I think we're done at 3:00 right yeah
that's why I'm gonna press on because
the we're getting into the somewhat
cooler stuff because we're talking about
getting into a place where we can start
to break the rules everybody comfortable
with Collin all objects you've seen this
kind of thing would under call in it
that that is a way to build a function
from a class definition what's really
important is you know you've got the
class width under call init and you
create an instance of the class the very
first time you show a colleague or the
first time you try this yourself you
always forget to actually create the
instance of the call above class and you
can ever figure out why it doesn't work
and then oh yeah I gotta make an
instance it's the instance of the class
is the callable object the class itself
is just the class doesn't do anything so
important important side note you know
define the class make sure that you have
the call method in there and then
dun-dun-dun you have the callable object
so this is a much more complicated
callable object it has dunder call in it
that's the only thing that matters
it's got type hints too but it's got
some other things going on you can see
in the dunder init it's got a local
variable and you can see that it's using
that local variable so that it does not
recompute things and will I'm gonna
review the methods here one Z by one Z
so done during it has this previous
which is an empty dictionary we're gonna
implement a technique here with the
baffling Greek name of memoization not
memorization there is no are in
memoization I even have a Greek
brother-in-law but I've never bothered
to figure this one out because the usual
explanation is Greek is the pure
language and your derivative Latin
English nonsense is nonsense and like
thanks a lot for they help me a toast
now can we talk about memoization
No have some more red Sina so here's the
call the dunder call which has its
argument integer and returns an integer
and it checks to see if the result has
previously been computed if it hasn't it
computes it and if it has it returns it
saving potentially centuries of
computation in recomputing things which
are already known so here's an example
here you know fact is factorial of five
the first time it does this it's going
to compute it it'll take a few
milliseconds the next time it looks it
up in the dictionary and it takes a few
nanoseconds the savings can be
breathtaking
so the compute is just a sort of a
standard recursive definition in it in
this case standard recursive definition
of factorial it uses the dunder call in
case a previous answer is useful in
computing the current answer so that
after you've computed five factorial
computing six factorial is really really
fast it's a multiplying a lookup instead
of six multiplies
so this compute is doing the the real
work underlying the hood here the issue
here is that technically we have broken
the hysteresis rule ideally you're not
doing anything evil with this but you
could you could save all kinds of crazy
derived values you could do all kinds of
insanity and a callable method nothing
stops you except of course future you
saying well is this stateful well it's
not computing the same thing every time
well but idempotency is like a
fundamental idea behind computing what
what did I think I was doing here so you
will hate yourself if you break the
basic idempotency rule with this
can be confusing if done badly you bet
it is
so one of the things that is a bit of a
tricky thing here is that my engine
mapping function if I try to make this a
callable I've got a bit of a problem
anybody know what that problem is gonna
be with floating-point numbers being
approximations and not really having
exact equality when I go to ask if a
particular value is in my previous value
dictionary what are the odds of any two
floating-point numbers being exactly
equal approximately zero they're always
off by one of the 64 bits so I'm gonna
wind up with every different version of
2,100 RPMs represented as a floating
point number
2100 point oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh
120 100 point for its Mike cash is going
to be polluted with a lot of nearly
equal floating point values so think
twice about memoization when you're
dealing with things that have lots and
lots of precision ordinary floats are
not a good choice for this but if I
round them off to the nearest hundred
now they're integers now they're gonna
match exactly my cache is not it can be
polluted with a bunch of nearly equal
values and performance is going to pick
back up again floats of course because
they're approximations are well they're
not evil all right floats are evil well
they're not really it's not like they
want to be evil it's just that they're
drawn in an evil direction by the fact
that they're truncated at 64 bits and so
that last bit is always a sort of a
sketchball situation and when you
multiply to where the last bit of
sketchball now the last two bits are
sketchball and when you start adding
those things together two three four
bits of that number are all kind of
sketchy at the end but there they are
you can't get rid of them so we remember
floats are drawn any evil do
correction by the waves we use them so
be cautious date time stamps also can
have a lot of precision the Python
date/time object goes out to what
nanoseconds microseconds so you can wind
up with nearly equal time stamps that
you wished were actually equal but they
happen to differ just for no good reason
that doesn't involve float that just
involves ordinary inaccuracies of the
clock so you've seen this callable
function you see how that that looks how
you might use it my collar ball engine
function got that next 100 thing going
big time to make sure that I'm only
dealing with rounded off integer values
when I'm doing memoization so that I can
be darn sure they'll match something in
cash as opposed to a lot of near misses
and a lot of pointless recomputation and
in case you're curious you can actually
type that in there at the command line
and find out that 100 plus a third minus
100 is not a third anybody needs to have
the doubts released on their mind this
is it always good for a laugh in the
slack channel here at Capital One we
will often pile on the people and shame
them publicly when they discover this
because it is kind of a surprise
floating point numbers don't fit the
abstract definition of real numbers and
it can be very very bitterly
disappointing that they're truncated and
that they're rounded off and bad things
can happen
so mutable objects in a cache like list
list doesn't have a hash value so it
doesn't have a simple lookup as a
dictionary key it does have an equality
test but it can't be used as a key in a
dictionary receta
so Dix lists and sets and objects you
define are not good candidates for a
memoization algorithm unless you
carefully define hash and equality tests
which wanders far afield from the five
kinds of Python functions
but when you're defining a function that
you're going to use memoization and
improve performance of it you wind up
sometimes discovering other things about
exact match equality and hashing
inequality tests so I have some other
things that I'm not going to talk about
because they're complicated they're fun
but I want to talk about decorators
because they're more interesting
decorators are higher-order functions
that's that from funk tools import LRU
cache weight it caches results for me
yeah you don't have to write your own
memoization it's in the funk tools
library you just use LRU cache in front
of things you can give it a size of a
cache like I want to catch the leet last
recently used hundred and twenty eight
distinct values and then your function
will have a buffer of 128 recent values
and computations will tend to proceed
really really quickly for those and if
it's not in the cache then it has to be
computed slowly and you didn't lose
anything and it costs you two lines of
code and import and a decorator so that
little at decorator business
occasionally mystifying but what's
really happening under the hood is the
decorator is a higher-order function so
at decorator is literally the same thing
as defining the function and applying
the decorator to it as a function said
it's a higher-order function that
returns a new function that has been
decorated you can write your own they
often look like this with type hints but
that's really not exactly what you want
but you have to do a little more subtle
type in ting to get it exactly right but
the basic intent of a decorator is a
function comes in a function goes out
I'm gonna skip over some of the details
because there's better examples of this
and the clock is ticking but really func
tools wraps and you're gonna return a
decorated function and that it's
generally pretty straightforward
decorators ought to be narrowly narrowly
focused on doing one small thing and it
is in a way functional composition so if
I have some decorator applied to a
function it is this you know D little
circle f of X I've created a new
composite function out of the decorator
and the underlying function it is a
because it is functional composition
it's higher-order function stuff and you
can use other higher-order function
syntax if you want to like math chains
of maps or generator expressions but you
are explicitly refactoring your code
into the decorating piece and the
decorate Ted piece and the thing that is
doing the decorating it better be pretty
Universal and pretty simple so that it
can be applied widely it's a tough part
of me so that's why there aren't giant
libraries of fancy decorators because
there aren't those big problems LRU
cache wraps properties there's a few but
there aren't very many decorators
because they're not wonderful uses for
them so final topic which I'm going to
jam into moments the yield function I
mean the the yield statement inside a
function so here's a function that does
an ordinary scalar calculation you give
it an argument it does its little thing
and returns a value not too surprising
this is the stuff we've been talking
about the computation is immediate if
I'm going to use this function
repeatedly I'm gonna wind up with things
like this where I'm calling the function
and appending values and calling the
function and appending values to build
up big lists of things but there's an
alternative way of looking at this and
that is by using the yield statement to
yield
values incrementally so they can be
consumed by list by
for statement by tuple I can make my own
lazy functions that lay around in the
couch until the value is demanded so
here's my iterator over the syracuse
function I give it a value and it yields
the number and then as long as the value
is not 1 it applies this Syracuse
transformation it yields another number
this is a kind of a fractal generator
this sort of thing and it will generate
a sequence of values and the important
thing is it generates them only as
needed until I write something like this
the function does nothing it's the for
statement that is consuming the values
that forces that Syracuse itter to then
generate and yield values one at a time
as needed so this does not build a giant
list data structure it consumes almost
no memory at all because it's only
generating the values as they need to be
consumed
I can build lists if I want to but a lot
of times I don't even want to build the
list I only want the length of the list
I want to know how many values are in
there I don't even want the values I
just want to know how many were in the
list because of the way the generator
works I want to know how big the
sequence was the actual sequence didn't
matter just the size some alternative
styles of it higher order functions that
make decisions and in the interest of
getting out of the room on time for the
next group anybody here work with the
project Euler problems a couple how many
of you done
a dozen anybody else yeah
I had somebody who did 200 in one of my
classes I was like I have to sit down
now it took my breath away but this is
the project Euler 14 done in a couple of
lines of Python it turns out take a
picture of this you type it in you run
it then if you've got a Macintosh it
starts cooking eggs I didn't know there
were that many fans what the heck is
that noise you know Neil do that for
like a half hour
fans thundering away all the little CPU
clocks all at a hundred percent you're
like well maybe this is not an effective
solution LRU cache is missing from this
so once you figure out where caching
goes a couple of seconds Oh
answer so you need to think about some
of these things holistically how am i
doing functional composition what
functions am i composing how can I best
represent the data for functional
transformation and in many cases how do
I avoid state because the whole point of
all of this is to avoid needlessly
complicated stateful objects we're doing
almost all of these things with simple
scalar types and named tuples so we
looked at ordinary def and return we
looked at the higher-order functions
which it turns out there's hardly
anything to those so they're well worth
a lot of our time exploring them to find
out better ways to express algorithms
using the higher-order functions and
functional composition functions as
wrappers and the important question of
when does it go in the class and when
does it maybe something that gets bound
onto the class and when should I just
wrap a method with a wrapper to make it
easier to use these are tools at your
disposal to make your code easier to
live with and more expressive of what
you're working on the forbidden dance
Lambada I think they're a wonderful
thing and I think they're underused I
know there are some folks in the Python
circles that really hate
because they're kind of incomplete and
there's better lambdas in other
languages and stuff like that but I
think they're very handy for expressing
a succinct piece of functionality so
that you can give it a name but it's got
to be succinct or lambdas are not useful
call little objects will let you break
the rules you can break the item potency
rule you can have stateful objects
stateful functions functions that
remember what they did before if all
you're doing is memoization that's good
if you're doing something fancier than
memoization you may want to think twice
about your design because you may have
gone down a bad road of having stateful
functions that don't return consistent
results break the idempotency rule and
leave people more confused than they
were in the past and generator functions
which I believe are the most useful
thing ever because you can process large
volumes of data without having giant
data structures in memory stuff gets
passed through a pipeline of processing
via generator functions very very
effective way to work with with large
amounts of data and things like
memoization as a performance and answer
because you get to cache previous
results and not recompute and LRU cache
it's part of funk tools you don't have
to do anything to make it happen you
just isolate that function that is the
one that the profiler says is using all
the time and and wrap it up so that it
memorizes its answer and and doesn't
compute as much any final questions well
cool thanks very much and I'll see you
for the next couple of days
[Applause]